han sido varios días de negociaciones a
contrarreloj pero finalmente los países
europeos han acordado poner un tope
máximo al precio del petróleo ruso tal y
como se había acordado hace unos meses
en el seno del g7 en concreto se pone un
techo máximo de 60 dólares por barril
aún así hay que tener en cuenta esta
nueva acuerdo no afecta en absoluto a
los países de la Unión Europea porque
hay que tener en cuenta que a partir de
este lunes 5 de diciembre ningún país
europeo podrá importar ni petróleo ni
sus derivados provenientes de Rusia sica
la práctica esto sobre todo lo que
afecta es a las navieras europeas que no
podrán transportar de ninguna manera
petróleo a ningún lugar del mundo que se
haya pagado por encima de estos 60
dólares el objetivo es asfixiar aún más
a la economía rusa porque dependen gran
medida de la exportación de petróleo
para que así otros países del mundo se
vean obligados también a pagar estos 60
dólares y reducir así los ingresos de
Rusia aún así esto evidentemente también
tiene un impacto en las navieras
europeas que tienen una importante cuota
de Mercado sobre todo las griegas y
chipriotas aún así Fuentes diplomáticas
aseguran que este es un buen acuerdo y
que creen que varios países del mundo se
van a poder sumar esta nueva medida
porque el precio del barril va a seguir
subiendo se espera que este nuevo
acuerdo pueda entrar en vigor los
próximos días muy probablemente antes de
que acabe el fin de semana